hearings on alleged u.s spying on
germany and possible collusion by german
intelligence agencies went late into the
night
this man star witness william binney a
former senior official at the national
security agency said the nsa wanted
total information control
another former nsa employee thomas drake
also testified
he said germany's bnd foreign
intelligence agency worked closely with
u.s counterparts
and had even delivered information that
was used in u.s drone strikes in foreign
countries
committee members were outraged
it's very important that we investigate
the exact extent to which combat
missions involving drones may have
originated in germany
after the hearing it emerged that a
german intelligence agent was arrested
earlier this week on suspicion of spying
on the committee
a government spokesman said that the
matter was being investigated at the
highest levels
we found out on thursday about the
allegations concerning the german
citizen the federal prosecutor is
looking into the case and ordered the
suspect's arrest federal police are
investigating
german media have reported that the man
was paid cash to hand over documents to
u.s agents
officials at the u.s embassy in berlin
have so far given no comment